[Music]
foreign
welcome to the special edition of
Hannity this Friday night Biden's
bribery allegations now tonight the
president of the United States Joe Biden
has been accused by a credible FBI
source of taking foreign cash in
exchange for policy decisions in other
words you call that bribery there is a
mountain of evidence now to back up
these very serious claims including
circumstantial evidence hard evidence
from Hunter's own laptop we have bank
records we have text messages eyewitness
accounts whistleblower testimony and
other recordings apparently exist and
yet this week the Biden doj Hunter
Biden's attorney they will working hand
in hand to sweep these allegations under
the rug forever and keep it from you the
American people but thanks to a
responsible federal judge it did not go
according to plan now Hunter's
sweetheart plea deal was rejected now a
federal investigation into potential
fairer violations other felonies remain
active and the bidens are reportedly
distraught they should be it is so bad
that Joe Biden is now taking the next 10
days off too stressful for him he's
going to hang out on the beach and try
and move his beach chair all by himself
and recuperate the writing is on the
wall and Decades of what is disgraceful
conduct now finally catching up with the
Biden family Syndicate take a look
what do you call someone this weak
Someone caught in a primary Scandal that
made them millions complicit in a
government cover-up and uses your
government to get special deals for his
family you call them Joe Biden
all right Joe's house of cards is now
crumbling around him now this week in
court Hunter directly contradicted his
father when he admitted to taking money
from China now that was something Joe
had vehemently denied in one of the
debates in other words Joe got caught in
a lie yet once again now meanwhile
Hunter's lawyers have now reportedly
been banned from calling the County
Clerk after they were accused the night
before the hearing of misrep
misrepresenting themselves on a phone
call to the clerk and according to the
allegations a member of Biden's legal
team actually pretended to represent a
republican Congressman in an attempt to
get evidence removed from a recent
Amicus filing a court that was on the
court docket but the Shady Behavior
didn't stop there look at this this was
the key paragraph this week that the
judge rightly honed in on and caught
wind of and it's paragraph 15 buried
deep in the doj's plea agreement with
Hunter Biden gifting the president's son
with broad immunity for a variety of
serious drug gun tax crimes but that
paragraph was not provided to the judge
until that day until she asked for a
copy moments before the hearing this is
frankly appalling behavior from Hunter's
legal team and Biden's doj but of course
the plea deal itself is also a disgrace
what two misdemeanor tax violations a
deferred gun charge after years of
selling access to corrupt foreign
Nationals they weren't paying for the
crack addict Hunter Biden's vast
experience at any of the deals that he
was doing he didn't pay his taxes he was
writing off sex club memberships and
payments to prostitutes on his taxes and
smoking mountains of of crack cocaine
lying on a gun application brandishing
that gun illegally before Lou losing it
in a dumpster across from a high school
thank God a Good Samaritan found it and
handed it over to the police but let not
your heart be troubled Hunter remains in
good standing with the bar in D.C
amazing and by the way most of Hunter's
possible Financial crimes not only
implicate himself it implicates the big
guy his dad the President Joe now
clearly the doj is not working for you
the American people now their main
purpose is to protect Joe Biden his son
Hunter the Democratic party it is now
corrupt it is politically biased and it
is taking a wrecking ball to the rule of
law our constitution the idea of equal
justice under the law and equal
application of our laws look at this
brand new op-ed in the Wall Street
Journal IRS whistleblower by the way a
Democrat Joseph Ziegler is calling on
the Attorney General Merrick Garland to
now appoint a special counsel to oversee
this Hunter Biden Criminal probe because
quote sweetheart deals shouldn't be
handed out like candy now sadly that's
likely not going to happen mayor Garland
seems to believe that his job is to
Shield Joe Biden and his family not
uphold the U.S Constitution now this is
more and more evidence of corruption is
continuing to emerge against the entire
Biden family but most importantly this
really isn't the big hunter Biden story
anymore this isn't the Jim Biden story
of the Jill Biden story this is about
the President Joe Biden and on Monday
Hunter's longtime business partner Devin
Archer he's set to testify before
Congress now Miranda Devine of the New
York Post great reporter she is now
telling us that Archer witnessed one of
dozens of phone calls between Hunter
Biden's foreign business partners
foreign Nationals where the big guy Joe
Biden was looped into the meeting on a
speakerphone why to impress Hunter's
clients and seal the deal now remember
Joe Biden swore that he never once spoke
to his son about his farm business
dealings as it turns out Biden actively
participated and then clearly lied about
it to the American people over and over
again both as a candidate and as a
president so again this is not a story
about private citizen Hunter Biden Joe
and Hunter are tied at the hip on all of
this and according to my sources tonight
Hunter recently lived at the White House
he gets Secret Service detail look at
that he got a he got a federal motorcade
as Miranda Devine points out the Secret
Service even rented a thirty thousand
dollar a month house next to Hunter when
he lived in Malibu California but Biden
refuses to offer any Secret Service
protection for Robert F Kennedy Jr who's
what 20 percent in the polls despite
serious threats against him and prior
assassinations of both his father and
his uncle than President JFK so let's be
clear here Hunter is no ordinary private
citizen and this Scandal is not about
crack cocaine and the wildlife of a
crack addict this is all about public
corruption tied to Joe the president of
the United States and a complicit
Department of Justice that's why these
two committees Jim Jordan's committee
the house Judiciary Committee and James
Comer's committee the house oversight
committee these committees are working
in tandem looking at the Biden family
Syndicate and how the FBI and the doj
have been politicized and weaponized and
are being used to protect the whole
family Enterprise hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else